[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thanks for joining today this is going
to be another private live q a and I'll
do my best to answer questions in two
different forms
we will alternate between questions that
were submitted ahead of time and
questions in the live feed and I'm going
to start with some of the questions that
were submitted beforehand and the people
can add questions to the chat the more
specific the better
the broader they are the harder it will
be for me to answer if they're really
long I will probably also skip them so
try to keep things very concise
and let me just take a look at a few of
the questions here that are marketing
and PR
launch focused it'll be fun for me to
stretch these muscles since I haven't
done anything specific to these type of
topics in quite a long time so here goes
the first question that I have in front
of me is from John I'm going to keep
last names out of it but Jon if you're
going to launch a new fast casual
restaurant how would you gather the
crowd before building the restaurant I.E
making sure people would come when it
opens well the theme that I think is
going to recur in many of my answers is
one of risk mitigation perhaps I'm known
by some or thought of by some as a risk
taker because I do things like invest in
early stage startups which tend to go to
zero I would say very high percentage
maybe 50 to 70 percent of my investments
go to zero but you have to keep in mind
a number of other factors and this
relates to Poker and other games of
skill that are blended with a high
degree of chance
and part of that is say bankroll bet
sizing knowing your maximum downside
compared to your maximum upside so
that's just a frame
a perspective that I would like to
present as one I look through for
evaluating almost any type of question
like this any type of opportunity any
type of risk
so coming back to fast casual restaurant
what would I do how would I gather the
crowd before building the restaurant I
would look at low risk capped downside
ways of experimenting with this concept
so for instance in Austin Texas where my
home base is you see many successful
restaurants begin as food trucks why
because the build out of course is much
less the regulations surrounding food
trucks in some respects far less onerous
than those of restaurants
and
you could potentially prototype taking
that type of approach a even lower cost
approach could be having a pop-up in
another restaurant and when I lived in
San Francisco there were a number of
restaurants that were later successful
that began as pop-ups so say Thursday
nights or probably an off night so maybe
a Monday or Tuesday night in a given
retail location where they are
effectively renting the infrastructure
of a pre-existing restaurant now I'll
leave it to you and your lawyers to
determine the legality of that but
nonetheless many successful restaurants
I'm aware of in San Francisco began that
way and it was important they began that
way because they never got it right
immediately out of the gate so I think
it would be a big mistake to just YOLO
all of your chips in at once and try
this concept hoping that the crowds will
get there or assuming the crowds will
congregate if you haven't really kicked
the tires so another option would be a
pop-up in another restaurant and there's
a book it's out of date it is out of
print probably called a gorilla
financing that may also give you some
ideas for how to bootstrap in different
capacities I found that book very
helpful when I was bootstrapping one of
my first companies
but the the point here is really to
identify the risk factors and this
relates to an exercise that I do at
least once a quarter many of you have
heard of it called fear setting that was
the topic of my last Ted Talk which has
I think 10 million views or so now
identifying the risk factors and going
down the list Risk by risk and trying to
identify how you can either eliminate
those or mitigate the likelihood of them
occurring so for instance if you had a
pop-up and you wanted to try to draw
some type of crowd and really your goal
is is iteration and Improvement of your
concept of your menu of the experience
you could partner potentially with say
organizations or groups who would stand
to benefit from a REV share so I'm
making this up I don't know exactly what
fast casual refers to here let's say
it's fast healthy you could approach
local CrossFit Gyms or gyms of some type
and say hey for every person you send to
this restaurant I will give you
what do you care you know 100 of the
profit you don't have to give them 10
you don't actually need to make a profit
as long as you break even so beyond
covering costs you could just say I will
give you all of the revenue that comes
from any of your members you sent to
this restaurant because again what
you're trying to gather is feedback
first and foremost so you can improve
before you have more sunk cost in some
type of say food truck or retail
location all right here's a question
from Matt what would be your approach if
you wanted to raise awareness of a new
productivity tool is genuinely different
from any of the approaches taken so far
and helps people apply the great advice
they know but don't follow easy to pick
up and use just minutes a day
there's free versions but I have no list
or platform to gain initial traction
share to bloggers podcasts Etc in the
space any advice welcome and thanks for
the council and company over the years
so I have a few recommendations here
and the first is really
observing people ideally not just asking
people and I'll just draw a contrast
here if you think you have a great idea
for a business or it could be a product
based business or service based business
and you ask your friends would you buy
this would you pay x amount for such and
such a thing
in most cases we will have some friends
maybe most of our friends will say yes I
would absolutely do that
however their behavior changes a bit
when you then put out your hand and say
fantastic I'm taking pre-orders I'll
give you a 20 discount could I take that
payment now
so the point is asking for opinions and
getting people to take action are two
very very different things and likewise
observing people using a tool is very
different from asking them how they
might use a tool so what I would suggest
in this case is before you even think
about launching make sure you're solving
a problem that people want solved
if something has never been done before
I find this very important to put under
scrutiny and really pay attention to so
one of my first steps might be paying 20
people to use it that might sound funny
if there are free options available why
would I pay someone you're paying
someone for their time and feedback so
this will sound very similar to my first
answer and you could pay 20 people to
use it and observe exactly the flow
through the product exactly their
feedback encouraged them to speak out
loud there are services that provide for
this usertesting.com would be one
example I haven't used it personally but
I know startups who have maybe beyond
your price range but you could also take
lower Tech options or off-the-shelf
options you could have people record
themselves using something like Loom
which is a tool I use a lot for screen
capture for training employees and
contractors feedback on various designs
so you could have them simply capture
their experience on say laptop with
something like Loom and then share those
with you and you could you could find
these people to test your product on
Craigslist or really just about anywhere
or you could do this in person and I
know a number of well-known CEOs who
began their companies that now have a
thousand two thousand five thousand
employees
by recording user testing sessions in
person with video so you could simply
have them in front of you at their
laptop encourage them to speak out loud
and you have an iPhone or something and
you're simply recording the screen as
they walk through it so that you can
correlate things properly
but I would say begin with
more intelligence gathering that's where
I would start and then in terms of how
to get the word out sending
free software to bloggers podcasts that
are in the space can't hurt but you're
going to need to have a good pitch and I
get sent
or I should say people attend to send me
thousands of different pitches per day
literally thousands so the vast majority
I simply deflect because I don't have
the bandwidth nor does my team have the
bandwidth to even digest or read these
pitches so to think of other approaches
the way that I have tackled this with
each book launch as an example is
looking for the neglected but powerful
Channel and then also the nascent up and
coming channel that is ramping in
influence
and for the first book for our work week
that was bloggers for instance most
people are like blogs what the hell is a
Blog in 2005 but at the time I knew that
they were pulling more weight for Book
Sales in some respects Than The Darlings
of network television and syndicated
radio at the time so I paid a lot of
attention to that for the four hour Chef
it was podcast this was in 2012. after
which I launched my own podcast in 2014.
so
I would also look at the landscape of
tools and another question I would ask
is which of these tools or platforms are
you actually going to engage in for the
long term you don't have to decide that
up front but where do your natural
skills and enthusiasm overlap such that
you will have staying power if you're
not gonna have staying power chances are
Beyond a flash in a pan it's not going
to be helpful you can still use one time
only PR approaches much like I really
targeted dig.com digg.com founded by my
friend Kevin Rose way back in the day to
try to get on the home page for
launching the four hour body because I
understood the power of dig at that time
for acting as a front page shopping list
a taste making service of sorts much
like landing at the top of Hacker News
or something like that today so those
are a few thoughts and I will come back
to some related themes in the next
question that I'm going to go to some in
the live q a so don't worry guys so
here's the third one this is from Josh
and I'm just going down in order that I
have them in front of me
this is a question related to advising
tech companies when you are advising
tech companies what were your most
successful marketing campaigns slash
contribution to the companies any
notable misses you're willing to share
let's see for those who have not seen
the range of companies that have worked
with you can go to angel.co Tim you can
see quite a handful there in terms of
most successful marketing campaigns
slash contributions uh contributions I'm
going to focus on because oftentimes
where I have aimed to help has been
unrelated to anything immediately public
facing so for instance for taskrabbit
way in the early days I helped
I helped Leah raise her first round of
financing when the the company was
actually
completely named differently based I
believe just in Cambridge or in the
Boston area and we met in the Bay area
so I helped her to Syndicate her
financing so I introduced her to to lead
investors who ended up helping her raise
money and then much later that company
was sold to Ikea in other cases it could
be related to helping companies
apply needed leverage or user pressure
for say
regulatory purposes and and I I was very
active in this capacity with Uber
particularly with some precedenting
examples
where situations were very very high
stakes in places like Washington DC so
with my platform
and the other types of back Channel work
those are
that's a separate category of help that
I sometimes provide in terms of
marketing I think the most notable
example
is probably and there are many many many
examples but the most notable well-known
example is probably the build a business
competition that I helped to design with
uh Toby and Harley of Shopify and if you
want to read more about that there's
there's a fair amount out there there is
a piece in Fortune magazine called The
Invisible selling machine about Shopify
and this is a a huge piece in the
magazine some time ago and it goes into
quite a bit of detail about my
involvement in the build a business
competition and then overall what that
looked like
that was very very very high Roi High
leverage for Shopify and if you don't
have a fortune subscription you can go
to the web archive I think it's just
web.archive.org otherwise known as the
Wayback machine and you can grab a
snapshot and take a look at that article
all right let's hop into the live feed
and see what we got here I'll take a
self-interested one first this is from
Joe Chen what is your biggest project
challenge at the moment and how can we
support you I do have a very
absurd and I think hilarious and fun art
project coming out in the not too
distant future so keep an eye out for
that
at the very least just
taking a break to laugh at the whole
thing
when it comes out that's how you could
support but I'll keep moving here all
right uh this one is from Scott what's a
takeaway or lesson you wish more of us
listeners paid attention to slash
followed through with
I would say in this day and age probably
the low information diet as described in
the four hour work week and here's my
phone here I have not had any social
apps on this phone in two years and
that's not because
I broadcast that for sitting on my moral
high horse it's because I understand
that
it is playing a dangerous game to assume
that you can use
willpower and self-control at the very
least it is exhausting and you can save
your mental calories for something more
important
to have this type of
addictive technology embedded into your
phone with notifications
that you're subject to 24 7.
through which algorithms are being
wielded against you that have billions
of dollars and teams of data scientists
into UI experts behind them I think it's
I think it's unnecessarily challenging
to subject yourself to that and to
expect to be able to over
overtake that and single task
effectively much like and some people
say like well you just need I have
better self-control you can just use
self-control that may be true but I
could also have junk food littered all
over my house
and I can make the same argument I can
say well if I have enough self-control I
won't eat the junk food but it's a hell
of a lot easier just to remove all the
junk food from your house
so I do think the low information diet
this applies not just to social media
but certainly any type of push news
which could just be reactively picking
up the newspaper every day when you go
to grab a cup of coffee at a gas station
or something like that it doesn't need
to be digital but the low information
diet I think is
very much underestimated in its power
and if you can single task
for a few hours a day without any
interruption
which is why I use do not disturb and so
on on my laptop as well as frequently as
I do and my phone is almost always on
airplane mode
you will have a huge competitive
advantage over the majority of people
who are let's just call them knowledge
workers anyone who works on a computer
if you have the ability to single task
for let's just call it three hours a day
in a single block of time
you have an unbelievable competitive
Advantage so I would I would say the low
information diet okay this is a question
from renaline what are your thoughts on
sub stack is more of a pull way to get
information yeah I think that opting in
to highly curated
sources of information
that are either relevant to you in the
near term or actionable to you in the
near term
is far superior to
being lost in the waves and chop of
online assault that is uncontrolled for
talking about information so I think
newsletters certainly are far superior
you can still use them to procrastinate
in the same way that you can use reading
books as a socially acceptable way to
procrastinate so just be aware of that
and as Kathy Sierra once phrased it to
me focus on just in time information not
just in case information if you think
you might need to act on say the
contents of a book
six to 12 months from now it doesn't
really do you a lot of good to reading
now is my general feeling I would read
it closer to the point at which you need
to actually implement it but I would say
that something like sub stack or
newsletters in general I think are
superior in so much as they force you to
make decisions about high priority low
priority information ahead of time so
that you're not making all those
decisions on the Fly because look
we're all simple creatures and the
algorithms will beat you right whether
it's just showing like a picture of Kim
Kardashian's ass or some celebrity or
like who the hell knows it's gonna pull
you off task I don't care who you are
so just keep the junk food out of your
house
metaphorically speaking let's see
comment on uh
Cal Newport and great books on deep deep
learning deep work I agree with that
Isla questioned one of the most
enjoyable parts of your show is
listening to your personal journey and
your interviewees journeys of
transcendence any recent spiritual
shifts that you would not mind sharing I
don't mind sharing I was actually
recently in the mountains of New Mexico
and
experienced some of the most profound
and extreme time dilation I have I've
ever felt certainly in a sober state
with a friend of mine and so we were we
were hiking at altitude for on and off
for several days and
by say day three thinking back to the
morning of even day two or day one felt
like looking back to three weeks or four
weeks prior so being in nature
I think partially contributing to that
was the fact that we changed the
location so many times and that the
Topography of the land changed so many
times so it could as as well have been
four or five different countries we
visited given how different the
Landscapes were and the wildlife and so
on
but that time dilation I think
highlights something for me at least
which is
there are different ways to extend or
better set I think expand life to live
in an expansive State more often and
many of the let's just call them
post-economic extremely wealthy
successful in financial terms Founders
and CEOs and so on I know want to extend
health span which I think is a very
worthwhile objective looking at science
and technology for
extending healthy years right
however you can live a long time but
almost never be present I'm not saying
that's true for these people but I I
know people who live a long time but
they're so preoccupied about the past or
the future or the news or the politician
on TV or whatever that they have a lot
of time contraction time passes very
quickly for them so what if you could
design a life and pre-schedule
experiences such that you have the type
of time dilation I'm talking about where
let's just say even twice a year you
have two trips each week long and each
of those one week trips actually feels
like three months well
have you then in that case effectively
added
let's just say each one feels like three
months okay have you added six months to
each year by doing that in terms of your
experiential lifespan
if so that's very interesting and so now
you're you're living let's just call it
50 longer in your remaining years so
does that have the net net positive or
even a greater benefit than simply
extending your biological lifespan by
that period of time
I don't know I do think that's a I don't
think I know that's a question that's
been on my mind and we can certainly
pursue both but one is available here
and now and the others are more so a
scientific road map with possibilities
but I think this type of time dilation
through
very deliberately designed experience
and immersion is very
seductive and rewarding all right
so I think it's kale it might be kale I
apologize I don't know how to pronounce
it love your work Tim caught up with
Derek sivers in New Zealand a couple
weekends ago and told me he missed you
well I missed Derek too he's a great
he's a great great guy and has been on
the podcast several times so if people
haven't heard Derek Silvers on the
podcast they should and I do need to
catch up with him here we go this is
from Ben we have invented a way patent
pending to add a second story to a house
without the owners moving out this
product and process is revolutionary for
so many people however we keep going
back and forth about whether to create a
franchise model or just to sell the
proprietary system that allows you to do
it the catch is that it definitely
requires training to use it properly
love to get your feedback about how you
would launch it very grateful for you
and the value you have brought to my
life well thank you Ben
here are my first thoughts so
construction adding stories
Etc does not sound at least immediately
to me as a liability free Endeavor so I
assume there are some risks involved as
you mentioned and I think kind of
implied that it takes it definitely
requires training to use it properly and
using it properly seems important so
looking at this again through the lens
of minimizing or capping your downside
risk I would say a lot of folks think
about business risk in terms of profit
and loss how much does it cost me to
make X how much can I sell X4 what is my
margin can I cover my various costs
maybe employees Etc but there are other
factors that are often neglected so in
in this particular case there are
questions around legal cost and legal
liability so I know that developing and
rolling out a franchise properly can be
very Capital intensive if you're the
franchisor
and I wouldn't underestimate that so
step number one I think in evaluating a
number of these would be running some
models and putting together just basic
mathematics
based on conversations with competent
legal counsel and there are people who
specialize of course in both of these
there is also a great book by Stephen
key
called one simple idea turning your
dreams into a licensing Gold Mine while
letting others do the work it's a great
subtitle I didn't realize that was a
subtitle but one simple idea by Stephen
key he is an exceptionally successful
inventor who generally does not venture
meaning he doesn't generally manufacture
and distribute and sell product himself
he's coming up with ideas often with
very inexpensive prototyping and then
licensing those ideas to other other
companies in in most cases so that book
I think is worth a read not because it
is immediately comparable since he's
mostly operating in the world of toys
but I do think it will raise questions
that are valuable for you
another one to look at is built to sell
this is a book by John Warlow so if
you're ever
considering the possibility of being
able to sell this company
and that I think is worth looking at
even if you've never considered that
possibility because it will help you to
identify where you as a proprietor as a
business owner
could end up being a bottleneck whether
it's for scaling the company or
ultimately for not just scaling it but
selling the company so take a look at
that and on the legal
cost and then liability side I would
just say one idea that immediately comes
to mind and this is not legal advice
please speak to your properly vetted
attorney for this but
potentially there there may be the
option of partnering with a larger
company who can run uh pilot
studies or experiments in implementing
this technology and you could have a
licensing fee you could have some other
type of arrangement they could take a
potential Equity stake in the company
although that seems potentially
premature at this point and the reason I
I bring that up is if they were willing
to test this technology
you could and speak to your lawyer but
you could potentially be added as an
additional insured so named as an
additional insured on their insurance
policies
it may be relevant to have you added to
their errors in omissions policy but
these are ways of
being covered by their insurance
policies and therefore the premiums that
they pay
which in the early stages if you're
bootstrapping could be non-trivial so
those are just a couple of things that
come to mind in terms of how to launch
it you know one of the benefits again of
possibly partnering with larger
companies they assume the Financial Risk
a lot of the legal risk of implementing
this and you can see if it actually
catches do people want this can this
company sell it can's company implement
it without assuming all of those risks
yourself
okay a couple of people asking about the
O2 breathing device that boss Bruton and
I had talked about yes I have been using
it and I've actually found it
tremendously helpful and I don't think
that's purely placebo effect I used the
O2 trainer to prepare for my extensive
hiking at altitude New Mexico and I
found it to be very very helpful and
easy to use and Incredibly soreness
inducing
oh
when you hear boss say with the back
breathing as an example don't start with
30 repetitions start with 15 take him at
his word if you do more than that you
will feel like someone hit you with a
pickaxe up and down all of your muscles
around your rib cage and mid-back the
next day or two or three so it is
then seemingly very effective for
stressing and applying a workout to your
inspiratory muscles so I for one plan on
continuing to use that device so this is
a question from Mead I hope I'm getting
your name
correct would you please share any
current recommendations that provide
hope or encouragement to a caregiver
amid a chronic medical situation
thank you so very much for sharing your
experience so first I'm very sorry that
you were in that situation
or someone you know is in this situation
and the the only advice I can really
think of offhand is uh I guess it's
twofold the first is an interview I did
with Dr B.J Miller quite a few years ago
who is a hospice care physician also a
triple amputee who has helped thousands
of people to transition so that
conversation which is on some levels
deeply philosophical I still act on and
revisit a lot from that conversation
I personally find a lot of it incredibly
actionable and impactful so I would
suggest potentially giving a listen to
that and secondly I would recommend a
book that has been recommended to me
several times including my friends who
have lost parents unexpectedly and that
is on Grief and grieving
and I'll find the author right now
okay on Grief and grieving by David
Kessler and Elizabeth Kubler-Ross
and
all of the people who have recommended
this book to me have said they wished
they had read it prior to anyone passing
away then in fact it also acts as
fantastic preparation
and consolation
if you may be on the verge of losing
someone and we're all on the verge of
losing someone in the grand scheme of
things in the grand scheme of life so
that would be a second recommendation
and apologies if those aren't
appropriate but given the context I have
those are the best I can come up with
all right let me see if I can pull up a
few more here
you're welcome in so there's a question
this is a question from Carrie can you
speak at all about any current
information you or any other of your
previous guests have on ketamine and
bladder damage so for those who have not
heard it I would suggest listening to my
recent episode with Dr John Crystal
who's chairman of the Psychiatry
department at Yale an incredible
researcher also in his own right who
along with other colleagues pioneered
research that identified the
antidepressant effects of ketamine in
humans speaking in this case of
intravenous administration but in that
episode we didn't specifically discuss
bladder damage
or urinary tract
symptoms and there is quite a bit of
literature to
support the assertion that that these
are
potential side effects especially of
recreational use of ketamine and
sometimes goes by the name ketamine
bladder syndrome and I would suggest
going to PubMed if you just search
PubMed p-u-b-m-e-d and you search
ketamine bladder or ketamine urinary
tract then quite a few reviews quite a
few papers will come up so in the
abstract here this is ketamine bladder
syndrome an important differential
diagnosis when assessing a patient with
persistent lower lower urinary tract
symptoms
abstract the recreational use Academy is
increasing in popularity due to its
dissociative and paralytic effects ease
of availability and low cost this is
from 2012 just to time stamp it however
serious and frequently erverse will
damage to the urinary tract is a
recently recognized side effect of
recreational ketamine use and this goes
on to present a number of case studies
so my understanding is and this I'm not
a doctor I don't play one on the
internet but my understanding is that
this is reasonably common in
recreational use but
I'm not aware of how frequently that
pops up as an adverse event in the
clinical trials that have been done and
those would be documented in those
studies so you could certainly look for
say John Crystal k-r-y-s-t-a-l
on PubMed and look at the studies and if
you get the the complete study not just
the abstract you can look at the
frequency of Adverse Events and most
certainly something like that would be
included I imagine but you can find more
in-depth information on PubMed which is
surprisingly easy to use and I find
generally quite user friendly even
though you may need to look up some
words now and again well here's one from
Sabrina I'm My Own bottleneck in my
business is that bad it's not
automatically bad depends on what you
want to do with your business right if
you are a
artisanal high-end leather pant maker
and I actually read a case study about
such a person who makes
super high-end leather pants or did at
least for people like Sheryl Crow and
Mick Jagger Etc then you are an artist
you are the business you are the Artisan
who is producing your craft and
if you choose that and you're accepting
the good with the bad
then I think it's 100 okay of course it
is it just depends on what you're trying
to do and there is no right answer
to that I know many business owners who
have chosen not to scale very very
deliberately and I actually find those
counter examples
to today's Gestalt and drive to scale
and build say public companies or
companies that get acquired to be very
refreshing because it doesn't get as
much
fanfare
but there is a book that I haven't read
in a very long time but I really enjoyed
it when I did called small Giants the
subtitle is companies that choose to be
great instead of big and is a book by
Beau Burlingham
b-u-r-l-i-n-g-h-a-m so small Giants but
I very much enjoyed that book when I
read it and in fact the example I just
gave you could have come from that book
there's a decent chance that it did all
right this question from Al what blogs
and newsletters are you excited about
reading or receiving every day there's
nothing that I receive every day there
are at most newsletters that I get once
a week
and there are very few I mean the micro
dose which is from UC Berkeley and gives
a synopsis of happenings and news events
in the Psychedelic spaces of interest to
me but very few newsletters and in fact
even with other writers I really really
enjoy
so for instance bear with me a second so
Matt Levine of Bloomberg for instance I
think Matt Levine is one of the best
writers and by best I mean not just
prolific because because that is not the
measure volume is not the measure word
count is not the measure necessarily of
a good writer but his his combination of
volume and insight like the density of
insight to words per page is staggering
nonetheless
I know that I have three or four friends
who read Matt's work religiously and I
depend on them to forward me specific
Snippets or specific newsletters that
they know align with what I am focused
on at the moment
but if I were to add say one other
newsletter to my regular consumption
rounds it would probably be from Matt
Levine there are a handful of others I
find interesting but there's nothing
that I get on a daily basis and that is
by Design question from Megan what are
the first steps you're planning to take
on the animal communication Journey well
there are a number of them and for those
who don't know this is something that
came up in my recent conversation with
Dr Gabor mate
one of them is identifying one of the
steps is identifying where animal
communication can actually be tested if
this makes sense
and this comes up in all sorts of fields
if you're trying to find an expert right
how can you identify let's just take a
different field
there are many folks in the U.S and
elsewhere who claim to be animal
tracking experts but how can you as a
non-expert in animal tracking assess if
someone is full of [ __ ] or The Real
McCoy the short answer is generally you
can't but if you
look for
the exception and the exception is any
type of system or company or
organization within which trackers are
actually tracked themselves numerically
then you can start to get somewhere and
in my case I ended up looking at safari
outfits in Africa that keep records on
trackers because they could identify for
instance that the average for
let's just call it leopard tracking
successful leopard tracking during these
hours is 23 percent but so and so has an
average of 71 percent as a success rate
and you get almost Major League Baseball
statistics Animal by animal
time of day by time of day for these
different trackers and then you can
start to assess on an objective level
who is actually good
this is even more difficult with
something like animal communication
depending on how we interpret it but I
would I'm starting with I would say two
things the first is revisiting dog and
training at mammalian training although
a lot of such training is behavioral
shaping and using
non-verbal cues I'm okay with that
though by communication I'm not limiting
that to to verbal cues so it could be
using a clicker I'm going to be
revisiting Susan Garrett who is a master
dog trainer I had on the podcast how do
you know a dog trainer is good well for
me I looked for sports so she was a she
is a multiple time if I'm remembering
correctly National agility Champion with
her dogs
and these are objective measures which I
like I like to start there
and then secondly I'm I'm very
interested in looking at different
methods of hunting and how Hunters
interact with animals the most obvious
example that comes to mind for me being
elk where
not only are bull calls being used as a
way of drawing in Bull but also cow
calls of different types and there are
actually elk calling
competitions where people get on stage
and are asked by a panel of judges to
produce different types of calls and
it's mind-boggling I mean it's it's very
very impressive with some of these
Hunters can do so I think those are two
places where I'll start there are other
examples that are of interest to me that
I've looked into and will probably spend
more time on Equine Therapy is quite
interesting
from uh I suppose more of a physical
kinesthetic interactive perspective
but those are some of the jumping off
points that I expect I'll spend some
more time on question from Dan and then
I'm going to come back to the pr
marketing stuff with some of the
questions I have here Dan what is your
protocol prior to taking a three-day
fast to get your body ready
so when I fast again not medical advice
talk to your doctor before doing any
fasting uh you can't even get approval
to do extended fasting probably couldn't
get IRB approval to do three day fast in
humans uh depending on the circumstance
to be very hard it's really hard to do
scientific research on extended fasting
these days
in any case
what I typically do for a three-day fast
is
let's just say my fast is going to begin
after an early dinner on Thursday night
that is typically how I will line things
up don't do your first three day fast in
the middle of the week it's gonna [ __ ]
up your whole situation and you're going
to send a lot of emails you're going to
have to do damage control on so don't do
that so
leading up to them if my last meal
is let's just say Thursday at 6 pm
what I will do in the two days prior is
I will get on a
a sub maintenance calorie
ketogenic diet so I will be having
smaller meals than usual that are going
to be predominantly fat so let's just
say hamburger with some cheese and maybe
a side salad right but I will be
consuming fewer calories than thought
necessary to maintain my lean body mass
and you can calculate resting metabolic
rate and try to figure out what that is
based on all sorts of factors
so lower calorie keto for maybe two days
beforehand with a fair amount of
exercise to deplete glycogen stores a
bit and then last meal would be a
smaller keto meal on Thursday
sleep as long as possible
that's part of the reason the timing is
is the way that I set it up
and then beginning on Friday what I try
to do is prior to that set up Friday for
phone calls so that I could be moving so
I try to get away from my laptop and
move this will actually be very very
helpful for a whole host of reasons
but on Friday as soon as I get up I get
a huge bottle of water I fill it full of
electrolytes like element which is what
I which which is what I've been using
for a couple of years and maybe put in a
little bit of lemon just for for
flavoring non-coloric and then I will I
will walk and talk so I'll briskly walk
for three to five hours minimum
and take my phone calls this will help
on a number of levels you will still
have some residual glycogen and you will
break down some of that into glucose
that your brain can actually function on
Friday and you can have a bit of
caffeine don't overdo the caffeine one
of the mistakes that novice fasters make
is they feel a little sluggish so they
end up having way too much caffeine and
then that inhibits sleep
if you do not supplement with
electrolytes there's a good chance that
you're going to experience lower back
pain I won't get into the the mechanisms
responsible for that but very often
you'll have lower back pain especially
if you do more than a three-day fast
and you'll have
a cholinergic response where your heart
rate is really fast so I always
supplement with electrolytes these days
and it's it's it's water only now if you
want to have say some black coffee with
a little bit of pure heavy cream 100 fat
or a little bit of coconut oil I don't
think that
inhibits most of the beneficial effects
that we're looking for okay so then
that's Friday
then Saturday again same deal right you
don't have to walk as much but it will
still be somewhat helpful and in fact a
little bit of weight training can feel
very good cognitively
and then Sunday you're going to break
fast right not at breakfast time but
that night so then Sunday night around
let's just call it six seven whatever
you would have your first meal leading
out of the Fest and there are all sorts
of superstition around this like oh you
have to eat grated cabbage and you have
to do this and you got to start with
some unpasteurized fruit juice and this
that and the other thing my my
uninformed take or semi-informed take is
that that seems kind of nonsensical to
me if we were starving in any
circumstance would our body and
evolutionary drives require us to start
with shredded
cabbage I mean it just doesn't make any
sense to me so when I break fast I'm
generally breaking it with another keto
meal because I like to extend some of
the effects of the fast or at least the
ketogenic diet for a day or two
afterwards you don't have to do that but
I will very often break the fast with
something akin to the meals that I used
for the preparation for the fast and
those are those are some of the thoughts
that I have on at least how I personally
prepare for three day fast and Implement
three-day fasts your mileage will vary
and please get professional medical
advice this is a question from Dave are
you seeing any Trends in successful
non-profit launches I'm kicking off an
effort to generate and share Coastal
resilience data all right so the subject
area Coastal resilience data certainly
of interest to me
and what I would say is
study Trends in the for-profit world
launching non-profit Ventures launching
for-profit Ventures the principles are
exactly the same in my experience
I think some nonprofits have done a very
good job with promotional efforts I
think donors choose and charity water
are two that come to mind immediately
that are very good and have for a very
long time been very good at this
so you might take a look at those but I
would really borrow from the private
sector the stakes are generally higher
the talent and competition more intense
in the for-profit world so a lot of the
mediocre or B minus approaches will just
get massacred before they ever see the
light of day they won't actually
overcome any degree of competition so I
suggest that you look at the for-profit
world now for fundraising purposes
fundraising is slightly different than
selling a product although I think
there's more in common than there are
differences to be perfectly honest
but I would look at any number of older
examples we don't need to reinvent the
world here but what I would say is
and I've mentioned this book before but
I will repeat it because it'll come up
again in a second just as a proof point
so I'll give you evidence that this
actually does work the 22 immutable laws
of marketing get the older one not the
for the internet which is horribly out
of date get the older one that has the
beer examples the airline examples the
22 immutable laws of marketing and take
a close look at that also read one
thousand true fans by Kevin Kelly that's
on kk.org one thousand true fans and
last but not least read the 80 20
principle by Richard Coke k-o-c-h and
first two of those one thousand true
fans will take ten minutes to read the
22 immutable laws of marketing some of
which is not going to apply but a lot of
which will will take you maybe an hour
or two to read and then the 80 20
principle will probably take you a day
or two to read so you might sequence it
in that way but I would uh I would focus
on those
and then I'll give you maybe an
unorthodox recommendation
but uh in 50 Friday my newsletter if
you're if you're not on it check it out
Tim dot blog slash Friday about 2
million people subscribe let me take a
look at what I included recently that I
found led to a series I was very
interested in and it is a YouTube series
man I've been doing Five Below Friday
for a long time every week for I don't
know how many years eight years nine
years ten years Okay so
here we go
Business Insider has a YouTube video
series
about business collapses and one of them
I found fascinating called how the
Beanie Babies frenzy collapsed that's an
11 minute video
and when you watch how the Beanie Babies
frenzy collapsed which I recommend
because it may relate to a lot of the
implosions that we have seen and we'll
continue to see with some of the
activities in nfts and so on
but these historical examples can not
only teach you a lot about what doesn't
work but about what works so you
embedded in these how fill in the blank
collapsed are certain principles that I
think you can also borrow and apply so
that series by Business Insider I think
is exceptional I looked at a few of the
videos and found them all very very
instructive and each one had a number of
takeaways for me personally so I would
encourage also taking a look at that so
this is from Joel
Ahoy Tim it's gonna be a little long but
I'm gonna read it anyway I love your q
and A's I really appreciate the
opportunity to hear curious questions
from the gigantic diversity of people
you've helped so thank you for this my
question relates to the 22 immutable
laws of marketing by Al Reese and Jack
trout also thank you for introducing me
to this book in 2016. it has since
helped me build a business with 1.8
million lifetime sales for making
porcelain coffee mugs okay so this stuff
works guys it does work and I can't take
credit because I learned from the book
as well and I've applied it so I'm
simply passing along something that no
doubt was introduced to me by any number
of people all right back to the the
description and the question the problem
is that I handcraft each mug with my
bare hands using porcelain clay and a
pottery wheel I'm living the dream
making a living as an artist and I'm
obsessed with the art of the pottery mug
but it's pretty damn hard and I'm still
working on long-term sustainable profits
I've thought about Outsourcing to China
the porcelain capital of the world
that's fraught with problems so instead
of trying to grow by selling billions of
cheap mugs I've decided to grow my
business by hand crafting mugs worthy of
a higher price I agree with this
approach I think I think you do not want
to be engaged in a race to the bottom
however back to the text that means
creating a sort of luxury brand since
this doesn't exist today we're focusing
on law number one the law of leadership
that says it's better to be first than
it is to be better these mugs are art
but they're not better than the world's
best sculptures and paintings which
often sell for millions of dollars each
or fancy ass diamond encrusted purses
that sell for tens of thousands of
dollars each but I believe it could be
the first mug to inspire people globally
as a piece of art that you can enjoy
your morning coffee from every day law
number four the law of perception has
been one factor that helped me sell mugs
for five hundred to one thousand dollars
per mug nicely done
but the vast majority of customers want
a cheaper mug how would you evaluate
whether or not a luxury mug business is
worth pursuing and if you determined it
was worth pursuing what would you do to
grow all right
let's hop into this
so there are a few books I would
recommend checking out Joel
as usual I have many book
recommendations so the first which I've
not read in a very very long time but
may be helpful is a book called selling
to the affluent
that's by Thomas Stanley and you may be
able to find a summary and to determine
if it is in any way relevant to you one
way that I assess books oftentimes is
trying to find a Wikipedia page for the
book which will give you a synopsis of
some type so selling to the affluent by
Thomas J Stanley I found certainly
helpful at one point when I was
considering many of the same questions
for different businesses
uh the other book
may sound a little funny at first
because it would seem to be
anti-advice but
it is called
Deluxe subtitle how luxury lost its
luster there's a lot of alliteration
here it's hard for my hard for my tongue
to get out right now but this book is By
Dana Thomas I hope I'm getting the
pronunciation right Deluxe is the name
of the book how luxury lost its luster
and it talks about different high-end
luxury Brands and how some of them have
compromised themselves by Outsourcing
Supply chains and making other poor
strategic decisions but embedded through
the whole story
and the various case studies
is the cocktail of ingredients that have
made some of the most durable luxury
Brands the world has ever seen at least
in the last several centuries so I
really greatly enjoyed this book it's
got 3.9 out of 5 on Goodreads for your
particular case it's about 400 pages
long I think that is worth reading for a
whole host
of reasons
and then what I would say is
to your last two questions how would you
evaluate whether or not a luxury mug
businesses were pursuing so I I think
that and I I have this predisposition
too it's very tempting to try to figure
it out right to sit down with pen and
paper look at a few databases and decide
is this worth doing is it not worth
doing
that can be very time consuming it can
also be misleading maybe you have or
actually certainly you'll have partial
information
the question I would reflect back to you
is how could you test in the real world
whether or not this is worth pursuing
right so if you had pick a budget that
you're willing to lose five grand 10
grand how could you use that
to determine to test the waters to see
if people are willing to buy whatever
you have to sell and so what does that
mean luxury mug business right if you're
selling mugs for 500 to 1000 per mug I
don't know what changes in order to make
it a luxury mug businesses that mean
five thousand dollars per mug okay fine
ten thousand whatever the number is
there are people out there who will
buy such mugs another question I would
just add to this is what story do these
luxury mug buyers get to tell their
friends
if you look at the Contemporary Art
world you will see I'm not saying this
is the same but I think there are
overlaps the story [ __ ] matters a lot
right you can't just tape a banana to a
wall at Art Basel with duct tape and
have no story there needs to be a story
and there are there are many
documentaries
that you could consider watching the
price of everything
is a documentary about
about Contemporary Art and I found it
very very engaging and there are many
contrasting Styles in here so check it
out here's the description with
unprecedented access to pivotal artists
in the white hot Market surrounding them
the price of everything Dives deep into
the Labyrinth of the Contemporary Art
World it examines the role of Art and
artistic passion in today's money-driven
consumer-based society where everything
can be bought and sold
I really enjoyed this I really really
enjoyed it so this would be another
recommendation because there's there's
again no need to reinvent the wheel I
mean these are not necessarily
identically the people you're going to
be selling to but what does it take to
sell the highest priced X fill in the
blank whatever that is and in fact some
of my answers are going to be
overlapping with
a question from
a listener in Brazil
Carlos I'd like to know your thoughts
about how to Market a product design to
high profile people consultancy for
professional soccer players which
channel would you recommend are there
some case studies to which you'd refer
thank you for everything big fan from
Brazil okay
so all of the books Carlos this will
apply to you too
all the books and the documentaries I
recommended would apply another thing
that you can do is
study luxury Brands figure out who their
PR firms are go to the pr firm website
and look at their campaign case studies
see what they do right
and you can learn a lot by doing this
and you can create in the old days what
was called a swipe file where you find a
for many years whenever an ad convinced
me to spend money I shouldn't spend so
let's just say you know back when I was
making like you know 35 40 Grand a year
if an ad came across that convinced me
to buy something that was five hundred
dollars that was a lot of money to me
and if it actually convinced me to even
pick up the phone or get online to buy
it whether or not I completed the
purchase I would keep that I would tear
it out of the magazine or I would take a
photograph of it or I would otherwise
try to record it in some fashion let's
say it was a radio advertisement I try
to remember the text to type it out and
I would create a three-ring binder of
all the things that almost or did
convinced me to spend in an inordinate
let's just call it unreasonable
percentage of my after-tax income and
that is another thing that you can start
to do now you do not need to be a
professional Market analyst to do this
you just need to be aware of your own
behavior and what drives you to purchase
decisions or near purchase decisions
so just to reiterate something I just
said
Brands you admire that do a good job
campaigns that are doing a good job or
individuals who are doing a good job
with selling into luxury markets study
what they do figure out who their
publicists are figure out who they're
PR firms are and then study those
publicists and PR firms most of the time
both of those categories are going to be
providing campaign examples and so on
and you may even be able to get on the
phone to have an exploratory
conversation with these people all right
so those are those are a number of
examples and the
other question that is worth reflecting
back and this applies to Joel as well as
Carlos
that I
reverse engineer a lot for myself is set
the price first and then make it worth
it so for instance when I had an event
and I never do events I never produce
events so they're such a pain in the ass
but I did produce one very high end
event and I decided that I wanted to
charge
I think it was minimum ten thousand
dollars a seat and then it went up from
there so the sooner somebody bought the
the less expensive it was and then it
just went up in price so the minimum was
ten thousand dollars and I started with
that as a nice round number and it was a
I think a two or three day event then I
thought to myself all right I want to
charge ten thousand dollars how can I
deliver that much value in the first two
hours that people are there
so that I don't have to worry about it
like how can I over deliver in such a
way in the first hour or two that
everything else is gravy everyone is
thrilled they came
within the first two hours and that's a
creative exercise and I was able to pull
it off and that is because I decided on
a ultra high luxury price and then asked
myself how on Earth can I make it worth
it what are the different ideas I have
for making it worth it and
the ultimately it came down to sharing
the actual book proposals that I used
for the four hour work week and the four
hour body in entirety with a few things
redacted just for sensitivity and then
also
acting as a Matchmaker for everyone in
the room for the period of about an hour
to 90 minutes and after that
I mean everybody was was set in some
respect and for those people who might
want to borrow this format each person
got up
and
the format was give a brag you have to
give a brag about yourself
so you have to brag in some way then you
have an ask and then you have a give so
everybody in the audience I think there
were 100 or 120 people got up and said
this is who I am here's one thing I want
to brag about or maybe I don't want to
brag about but since it's a directive I
will brag about here's one thing that is
an ask this is what I'm looking for and
then here's one thing that I can give
that I'm really good at or relationships
that I have expertise whatever it might
be and I just encourage everybody to
take notes if you can help somebody
who hasn't asked go help them if you
need something that they have on offer
because that's a give go find them and
the rest of the event took care of
itself but I would not have come up with
those answers had I not asked the right
question it comes down to the right
question so start with the price that
makes it work right Joel luxury mug
business what does that mean how many
mugs at what price
right let's just say your goal is a
hundred thousand dollars a year well the
answer could take many many many many
many different forms is it a thousand
well let me let me step back we'll make
it we'll make it a million dollars
let's get ambitious million dollars a
year
that could be a thousand mugs at a
thousand dollars a piece it could be one
mug
at a million dollars
or could be somewhere in the middle
right and how can you mitigate risk in
these experiments well I mean look if
you look at different examples of
collaborations you have for instance
crypto punks now owned by Yuga labs
partnering with Tiffany to create you
know bedazzled customized crypto Punk
jewelry all right
how the [ __ ] do these things happen it's
worth digging into trying to find out
how those things happen what are the
mechanics what are the agreements what
are the responsibilities of the various
parties and not to not to not to be
labored that one example there are many
such examples so for instance
how do you or how could you potentially
have one or ten or a hundred of these go
into gift bags at the Oscars at the
Golden Globes or fill in the blank this
doesn't automatically work by the way I
mean I have had my books put into such
bags sometimes it has amazing effects
sometimes it doesn't sometimes it has
amazing effects you don't even know of
until 10 years later right so be
prepared to play the long game if you're
going to do anything like that and you
have to be prepared for your investment
to go to zero so if your material cost
and your labor cost is 10 grand maybe
it's worth rolling the dice if it's 100
Grand maybe not depending on your
financial picture okay
there we go so that's uh that's that I'm
going to come back to the live feed who
knew I had so much to say about PR and
marketing it's been a while hopefully
this is helpful for folks
all right let's get into the live stuff
and I'm just going to keep going guys
I'm having fun so if you guys are having
fun I will keep going we're about an
hour and 13 minutes in I'm happy to keep
going I've got my got my iced tea so let
me know if you're having a good time and
I will I will keep going and this luxury
mug example
should not be dismissed if you are in a
different business even if you are in a
SAS business software as a service
Enterprise SAS you might think this has
nothing to do with me it has everything
to do with you potentially depending on
your pricing tiers depending on your
funnel depending on what stage
your company is currently slogging
through right if you're if you've
already reached escape velocity and you
have all your pricing structures and you
have your entire sales force maybe not
but if you're trying to land the first
sap like customer maybe it has
everything to do with you so the
principles apply very very widely all
right let's get in here
go Timmy go thank you Ellie
I'm going I'm going Ryan any new
favorite travel spots to recommend
honestly I've been spending a lot of
time in the U.S the US has so much to
offer and as a young whippersnapper you
know in my early 20s it's easy to
fantasize about everything else in the
world while neglecting all the treasures
right in your backyard
so
Treasures could range from you know
North Carolina and the Smokies to
getting to let's say British Columbia or
the Pacific Northwest and the the rain
forests in the Pacific Northwest or
going to the Southwest going to places
like Moab there's so much diversity and
Beauty in the United States I've really
been trying to pay more attention to
what is in the U.S most recently
all right
Nick the Hair Band video is a great
addition to that five five bullet Friday
email I'm glad you enjoyed that that was
that was a music video from the Bullet
Boys which I listened to when I was
probably 12 years old and I just thought
I have to include this video
I think that was related to the Beanie
Babies
bullet as well
all right
ah Satriani yeah Russell Saturn is
amazing what a shredder so is Steve Vai
love to connect those guys sometime all
right Josh I'll keep this short but if
you wanted to displace outcompete and
established tech company with a similar
product how would you approach it from a
marketing lens assuming you had no
influence on product
this is going to sound funny it's
straight from the 22 immutable laws of
marketing but I would study Avis
you know we try harder versus hurts way
back in the day and the strategy was
more sophisticated than just that
tagline
if you're truly similar and
undifferentiated I think you're going to
have a hard time and you're probably
going to have to compete on price which
is a dangerous game because incumbents
with much more money can say you know
what we have 12 product lines we don't
like this competitor we don't want
competition so we are just going to sell
below our cost for a period of time to
bleed them of chips until they go out of
business and this is a very very
textbook common competitive approach
that incumbents use to spectacular
success against startups so I it is a
risky Gambit to compete on price but
that may be necessary at least for a
period of time
but beyond that in terms of
out competing or out marketing
I would say
you could do that on a whole lot of
different levels I would study the Avis
versus Hertz example and you could also
study for instance now this is going to
be a price dominant example but I read
the biography it may have been the
autobiography of the founder of Ryanair
at one point and looked at even though I
have no interest in participating in the
airline businesses looking at how
low-cost competitors and carriers
entered the scene and became at least at
points as dominant as they did EasyJet
is another a very very interesting
example certainly Southwest another
fascinating example
and I would encourage you to look at all
of those even though they may not seem
immediately applicable
so those are a few approaches that you
might take but
the commonality here is looking for
comparables not just within your
industry but outside of your industry so
which startups can you model that have
taken on incumbents with
similar products hopefully not entirely
identical but somewhat similar products
you can also use I'm not saying you have
to do this but sort of humor and
SAS is generally going to get
neutralized and killed in any
bureaucracy within a bigger company
which is why say
you know Dollar Shave Club and others
had a tremendous window of opportunity
that they took
excellent advantage of with their
advertising campaigns and I think even
though one could consider certainly
Branson Richard Branson a
an incumbent in some respects and he's
certainly not having to bootstrap things
with limited savings if you look at how
he competed uh and this is chronicled
quite a bit in losing my virginity which
was one of the books that had a huge
impact on me when I was in my early 20s
so losing my virginity by Richard
Branson talks about competing in the
music business and it also talks about
competing against British Airways with
Virgin so it's it's just happens to ants
I suppose that a lot of these examples
are Airlines but in a sense airlines are
the perfect example of largely
undifferentiated competition so it might
provide some variables and levers that
you can pull and play with tea over
coffee these days from Ryan my rule is
one I get one coffee in the morning
these days coffee really keeps me up
late at night more so than it should
given the caffeine content I can have an
equivalent amount of caffeine through
other sources whether it's even energy
drinks or iced tea and it will not keep
me up in the way the coffee does so as
it stands right now I'm having one cold
brew
from Starbucks in the morning before 10
a.m that's a rule and then after that
it's iced tea
am I cold I'm being asked beanie and
Hoodie yeah it's [ __ ] freezing where
I am so yeah I'm cold and I'm bald so
hence the beanie
all right let's keep going from Jeff
Steve Vai would be an awesome interview
advise unbelievable and spiritual I
believe it I've seen him interviewed
he's excellent so maybe that'll happen
at some point Justin asks any comments
or observations on limiting alcohol
intake
I have been limiting alcohol intake
quite a bit I actually have had my first
drinks in a month
beginning three or four days ago
so in prep for
the higher altitude and extensive hiking
and so on I did not want to compromise
my sleep getting ready for that and I
thought it would be a good
ascetic practice slash proof of
non-dependence to take a 30-day break
from alcohol so I took a 30-day break
from alcohol
felt great and
I know that alcohol especially once it
gets past two drinks obliterates sleep
so I have experimented with other
options
number one is simply not having alcohol
just having peppermint tea or whatever I
might want to have for flavor at a
dinner which is perfectly fine most of
the time I'm also looking at other
options there are some Ketone beverages
which are non-ethanol based
alcoholic beverages if that makes any
sense where you can actually get a buzz
from say
I think it's R Butane dial or an r13
butane dial let me just see what uh
yeah so one three butane dial also known
as r13 butane diol
is not great in my experience for
performance at all but it can give you
[Music]
a slight buzz and don't please do not
this is not food consumption advice one
three butane dollars used mainly as a
solvent for Food flavors so
FYI right so there are a number of
brands that sell
arbutane one three dial I'm mixing up
all of my my chemistry here so
there are some brands that sell hard
Ketone drinks and I have been
experimenting with those as an
alternative to ethanol based drinks
right like a gin tonic or something like
that
it does seem like the hard Ketone drinks
if consumed close to bedtime will still
negatively affect sleep so
if I consume alcohol I try to do whether
it's the hard ketones or ethanol I try
to consume it on the early side so if
I'm having an early dinner say 5 30 or 6
I want to give my body and my liver time
to metabolize as much as possible before
I lay down to bed and
that means I'll go out to dinner and if
I'm gonna have a drink as I did
yesterday for instance actually I had
two glasses of wine last night and I
sat at the bar instead of at a table so
I wouldn't be rushed and I had two
drinks while writing for about
30 minutes before getting my food
because what I didn't want to do is have
one drink with an appetizer eat a huge
entree and have two or three more drinks
just to feel the buzz and ultimately all
of that lands on my system and needs to
be dealt with
so those are a few of the thoughts I
have but I have dramatically cut back on
my alcohol consumption and that might
change I mean depending on where I go if
I'm going to Italy and I'm going to be
eating pasta and drinking wine
everywhere then I'm going to drink wine
everywhere you know it's not not a big
deal to me but as it stands right now I
have cut back very substantially all
right Stephanie suggests visiting shaved
ice Island in South Austin life-changing
Thai tea shaved ice on the menu I'm into
it I'll check it out all right Cherie I
think is the name here I hope I'm
getting that down properly with your
various Endeavors into Hobbies have you
ever tried archery and if so any
directions as to books teachers Etc to
check out specifically looking at
traditional longbow
yes I have looked quite closely at
archery and I've been spending the last
several months going deep down quite a
few rabbit holes related to archery I
have
one two
three four five
or six boats no more seven eight
probably eight bows within 500 feet of
where I'm sitting so yes I've been
getting into it that includes a
traditional Longbow made by someone
named Byron Ferguson who's who has a lot
of Incredible video online
and
I believe Byron has a book
called becoming become the arrow let me
see
yeah become the arrow second edition by
Byron Ferguson he has some of the most
incredible longbow
shots I've ever seen uh he is the one as
far as I know
who was first to develop the trick shot
progression of shooting a disc out of
the air that is about the size of say a
bread plate
and then shooting a golf ball out of the
air and then shooting a
Lifesaver out of the air and then
shooting an aspirin out of the air
using field points
so he's he's quite incredible Longbow I
think is very very interesting very very
challenging also
I am
quite interested in both Olympic recurve
and barebow competition so I'm looking
at both of those and most of my
experience
from a Precision standpoint is with
compound bows
but from the looking at a spectrum of
say
aiming let's just call it aiming on one
end of the slider and then biomechanics
on the far other end of the slider I
would say that compound bow
for me at least has the most in common
with rifle or or firearm Marksmanship so
if I were going to train someone for
compound and I'm not a professional by
any means but just to help someone get
accustomed to breath control and
aligning front and rear sights I would
actually have them start with prone
rifle shooting and
move from there to compound
and there are a million different types
of releases we won't get into that
but if you have compound there and then
on the far other end of the spectrum
with biomechanics you have Longbow then
I would put something like Olympic
recurve
close to the middle I would say and then
barebow would be somewhere between the
Olympic recurve and the longbow
but the the further you get to the
biomechanics side the better your shot
sequence people are going to disagree
with me on this but the the more you get
to the biomechanics side the better your
body awareness and kinesthetic control
and sequencing of your shot sequence
will need to be and I think that's
probably most easily illustrated by
watching video of say Korean archers in
Olympic recurve they're just
unbelievably good so take a look at take
a look at that but yes I'm very
interested in archery is the short
answer
here's a question from Joel you and
Stephen pressfield talked about writing
fiction on your podcast did that Inspire
your nft or have you tried other fiction
writing I have tried other fiction
writing so
there are a number of pieces that are
unpublished
short stories that I've not shared which
are fiction mostly because they're not
complete these are longer short stories
and then the first fiction piece I ever
published was put out as my first
experimental nft with Kevin Rose if
people want to check that out you can
read it online there's no issue with
doing that if you just go to tim.blog
nft
you can go on and just zoom in and and
read that story and if holders of that
nft are open to it at some point I may
just put you know three quarters of it
or the entire piece on the blog so that
people can actually read it I think that
would draw more attention to the piece
as well but I have tried other fiction
writing to answer your question
so this is a question from Cindy
when unexpected life or people
challenges try to knock you down
what go to tools help you keep grounded
I think that's what you're asking
are there two to three podcast guests
who brought those tools yes I would say
the people who come to mind are
immediately
first off the top of my head and there
are more one would be Tara Brock
b-r-a-c-h
who wrote an incredible book called
radical acceptance
so it's a tarabrock is definitely one
another would be Jerry Colonna
who has a number of questions that I
think are fantastic and worth keeping in
mind constantly including how am I
complicit in creating the conditions I
say I don't want that would be one
example of many
so we have tarbrock Jerry Colonna and
then I'll throw in Jack cornfield all of
his interviews I think are very very
powerful and the reason I bring those
three up is that when I feel I have been
hit unexpectedly with something or
perhaps I have precipitated something
happening that is undesirable
my defaults and I think this is from a
lot of family history as well are anger
mostly anger directed at myself but
anger and self-flagellation just
incredible self-criticism and
beating myself up mercilessly and for
those reasons I mentioned those guests
because for me it's not the events that
are the problem per se it's my reflexive
response to those events
being self-abuse through
inner monologue or dialogue and being
able to
number one create a greater awareness of
that number two
developing or borrowing in these cases
tool kits and questions that allow me to
calm that reactivity and not to push it
away necessarily but certainly in the
case of tarabrock to befriend in a way
to have a conversation with it or with
those parts is very helpful another
person I would add to that is Richard
Schwartz who is the founder of ifs I had
him on the podcast so those are the
first few names that come to mind
Andrew proud holder cool let me know if
you'd be if you think it would be a good
idea I think it could be interesting for
me to share the actual text from the
fictional short story in the nft let me
know what you think I'll keep an eye on
the on the chat all right Christopher
has questioned which mental model or
helpful tool do you often go back to
regarding prioritizing projects and
things you want to pursue
I'll keep it at that so
I have one really simple question that
Echoes also
a guest I've had on there's a very good
chance that I adapted this from Gary
Keller so Gary
is
legendary in the world of Real Estate
he is the co-founder chairman and CEO of
Keller Williams the world's largest real
estate franchise by agent count
2019 KW which also ranks number one in
units and sales volume the US was named
by fast company as the most Innovative
company in real estate so Gary is a
fascinating fascinating character you
can find him on Twitter at Gary Keller
and
the name of this podcast episode is how
to focus on the one important thing Gary
Keller how to focus on the one important
thing I'd recommend folks listen to this
he also has a book called The one thing
subtitled the surprisingly simple truth
behind extraordinary results
and
I believe the question that I ask myself
is adapted from this but I can't say
that with 100 certainty and that
question is this
in this list of things five or six or
ten things whatever your list of
priorities might be or to Do's which of
these if done make other things or all
of these things
either irrelevant or easier to do
and so look at this list of 10 things
which of these if done
make other items on this list hopefully
many or all of them easier to do
or irrelevant
and that is my sorting function that's
it now on top of that let's just say
that doesn't yield the clarity I'm
hoping for I could look at that list
again and ask myself which of these
if done or brought to the next Milestone
would leave me feeling proudest at the
end of the day
I know people who do this with workouts
I know CrossFit Champions who do this
with certain types of workouts just
asking yourself which of these if done
or pushed to the next Milestone would
leave me feeling proudest at the end of
the day that's another one and a third
would be if you're trying to choose
between say major projects you've got
this branching tree and you have three
different professional options let's
just say different projects different
Endeavors joint ventures whatever
creative projects I'll ask myself which
of these
even if it fails can be the greatest
success and that's a success in terms of
new skills
new relationships or deepened
relationships
and also Just Energy
which of which of these will give me the
most energy will I be most energized by
so I'll repeat that
three options having trouble choosing
between them let's just say they're
creative projects
which of these can be a success for me
even if it fails let's say the launch
doesn't work people don't want to buy it
Whatever It Is in terms of new skills
or resurrecting old skills in in the
case of me choosing my new absurd art
project right is resurrecting old skills
and uh so resurrecting old skills or
news developing new skills developing
new relationships or deepening current
relationships and then providing Life
Energy energizing you that is how I've
decided to spend so much time over the
last say six to 12 months on this this
hair Branch thing that'll come out in
the next few months
which absolutely could be
a flop on every commercial slash
Financial level so that's part of what
makes it kind of exciting to me honestly
so we'll see we'll see how it goes uh
John said the lead Domino exactly
choosing the right Domino to tip over
the tips over many others bill has a
question did the book 4 000 weeks change
your approach to life and living in any
way I thought 4 000 weeks was an
exceptional book and I plan to go back
and reread it I have a lot of Kindle
highlights and uh shared one chapter
in particular from that book on the blog
on tim.blog called Cosmic insignificance
therapy so if you want to read that
chapter I encourage everybody to read it
Cosmic insignificance therapy you can
find that on Tim dot blog okay this is a
question from Al if you had to build a
launch strategy for the four hour work
week in 2022 versus 20
2007.
otherwise known as 2007. what strategies
and channels would you employ which
strategies would stay consistent from
2007 and why
I think the the Crux decision which was
to
engage with people in person at events
at the time those were predominantly
bloggers now that might be different
but not necessarily blogs are still
actually a thing despite what people may
think but that core approach to taking
the uncrowded channel
of engaging with people in person at
events in recreational settings over
drinks would remain consistent and you
could remove every other
prong of the four hour work week launch
strategy
if I simply executed well again on that
type of in-person Engagement
I think the book would still be a
success today
and to reiterate how I did that or to
give one example
I would
go to the after party after some
conference event where people are on
panels and sometimes I would approach
them afterwards very often when I would
approach a panel I would not approach
the panelists who are getting mobbed I
would approach the moderator who is
undeservedly neglected a lot of times in
cases like this and chat with the
moderator usually asking a handful of
follow-up questions which are sincere
questions about the topics on the panel
they would at some point generally ask
me well what are you doing here why are
you here and I would say it's my first
time at this event
I just finished writing my first book
it's this this and this it's based on
guest lectures I gave at Princeton
University from 200xt
2000 why and I'm trying to figure out
how to launch a book since it's really
on me at the publisher effectively
prints and ships books I have to figure
out how to Market this
you know is there anyone you think I
might want to meet is there anyone you
think I might get along with and then
they would make a referral and I would
be on to the next referral and I would
repeat something like that each time
separately if I Came Upon say a group of
people bloggers let's just say I knew at
least one blogger was in this group at a
bar they'd be talking and I would wander
up and I would say something like hey
guys do you mind if I join in and just
listen in and they'd be like nah
whatever fine
and so I'd hang out and if I finished my
drink first I'd be like hey does anyone
else need a drink like don't be [ __ ]
weirdo just be a normal person but
anyway like hey does anyone else in your
drink I'm gonna grab another one okay
great get a couple drinks
and eventually somebody in the group
would be like so what's your story who
are you why are you here and I would
give some answer along the lines of what
I just mentioned and then I would just
stop I would not start pitching I would
not be I would not immediately start
humping their legs to ask them if they
wanted to read an advanced copy or
something like that but I would say that
and then I would I was sort of leave the
window open to more questions and then I
would see if anyone
took the bait and if they did that is an
indicator of at least I took it as an
indicator of Interest let's say one of
the people's like well okay so you said
your book is what's the book about and
then I would elaborate then maybe they
would ask some follow-up questions
and then at some point I would offer I
would simply say look it might not be of
any interest to you
I totally understand if you're just too
busy but there are I think maybe one or
two chapters that would be really
interesting to you if you'd like I mean
I have a ton of advanced copies I could
just send you a copy and put in some
Post-it notes for the 20 Pages or so
that I think would be most interesting
and I'd say
I don't know 60 70 of the time that I
went up to one of those groups at least
one person would be like yeah that
sounds cool yeah totally yeah please set
it and
that is a high labor approach that also
can have a very very high Roi
and
I would replicate that
I still think in person is the least
crowded it just takes a set of skills
that most people have neglected I think
in a world where everything is thought
to be digital and text first via email
the interpersonal piece I think gets
lost a bit in the
ability to navigate social dynamics in a
way that is
interesting but not
overwhelming or irritating takes
practice you got to practice this stuff
and fortunately I got a lot of practice
doing that on the phone and in person
in my first job out of college which was
being an outside sales rep
for fiber channel storage area networks
I had to
learn how to navigate this stuff so in
person still works or it can work
all right let me check out um some more
questions in the live chat
okay so Andrew on the how to start a war
why don't you just yeah chat with the
folks and proof who are holders and
um and see what they think I don't see
the downside I mean I really don't I
think it all it will do is draw
attention to it and increase interest in
it I don't I don't see the downside and
I certainly don't have to I don't have
to share all of it it could be I don't
know 70 or 80 percent okay here's a
question what's Your Gut response to the
metaverse and its potential use cases
very conflicted very conflicted I think
as much as people talk about
the
Utopia and ideology of decentralization
humans like centralized Discovery or
some centralized service where they do
not need to make decisions humans are
[ __ ] lazy
so and I'll throw myself in there too
honestly right
Discovery is hard and humans want
to identify taste makers or curators to
help them with making choices in areas
of high complexity or in situations
where there is a paradox of choice
challenge which is almost everywhere and
this will certainly be true in the
metaverse
and or The Meta verses although I find
that kind of
oxymoronic I guess let me start looking
at it that way so I do think that there
will be likely a handful
at most of
virtual spaces
like the metaverse
in snow crash let's say where people
interact through avatars right so let's
just call it a in a second life on Mega
steroids with all sorts of technological
innovations that have have started to
Crest in the last handful of years I
find it hard to believe that there are
going to be dozens and dozens and dozens
of these things
I just I find it hard to believe that
that will be compelling to users
if a few dominant players with massive
amounts of capital and employee
coordination
are focused on creating the most
addictive compelling versions of these
spaces
I hope I'm wrong but
if I've noticed anything in the last
year or two it's that people claim to
hate centralization but man do they love
it it saves them a lot of time and it
saves them a lot of decisions so we'll
see where it goes
oh yeah okay Enrique how's your
gardening going did you get this
gardening season if yes what worked and
whatnot there's nothing like trying
experimenting so yes the answer is the
gardening has worked hold on a second
so I'm holding up a huge basket of
veggies and uh this came right out of my
garden
a few hundred feet away we've got these
beautiful beans
that are purple in color but
you can eat them whole they're
absolutely delicious then we have
these amazing huge beets so check that
out
I'm gonna be eating a bunch of those
later today
got the biggest check out the size of
these things
like the biggest Swiss chard you can
imagine oh gosh
I mean that's Swiss chards it's the size
of my entire upper torso
so
it did work this year and it's the two
main differences are relocating the
raised beds so they have more consistent
sun exposure but above and beyond that
two things
setting up a very very simple
electric fence that can be turned off
and on it's solar powered and it's very
very thin mesh it's just to keep out
to the extent possible the deer the
groundhog you know all this kind of
stuff and then
second is an aeration system a timed
watering system
so simple
not that difficult to install and the
combination of all those factors
has led to just an incredible Harvest
this year for the first time ever in my
life
tons and tons of stuff
for whatever reason the kale gets
annihilated by pests everything else is
fine and intact the kale gets completely
killed I'm not using any pesticides
but for some reason the the kale
specifically is just the sacrificial
lamb it seems to get
absolutely naced by everything that
wants to snack on some domesticated
veggies so there you have it but thanks
for asking
Ranjit what is your workout routine
these days my workout routine's super
simple I go to the gym and I lift
weights
doing full body workouts this is called
twice a week that's weight training
I have a sled
a weighted sled that I push
I would say three to four times per week
in the morning usually after my first
cold brew
and I am intermittent fasting at the
moment where I will effectively not have
anything to eat until noon I say
effectively because sometimes I will
have a few macadamia nuts or something
like that but generally no calories to
very very low calories so I'm
intermittent fasting in the morning
and I'm doing kettlebell swings
right now I think I'm using a 72 pounder
for sets of 50 and really just doing one
set of like 50 to 100 reps
twice a week
and
I jump rope in the mornings oftentimes
before I do the sled pushing just as a
way to wake up my nervous system and my
my cognition honestly just jumping rope
for two minutes hopping around having my
dog bark her face off at me which is
hilarious
is is enough to change my mood to
elevate mood
sauna probably four to five times a week
uh generally before dinner so let's just
say I'm eating at seven o'clock I will
finish up my day my work day at five or
five thirty do the sauna for a half hour
and then take a cold shower post that's
about it that's about it I mean it's
nothing crazy if I go for a hike with my
dog which I do pretty regularly if the
weather permits I will throw on a
rucksack I have a go rucksack for an
hour hike I'm not using crazy weight
also because this rucksack does not have
a waist strap so I am supporting all the
all the weight on my traps and shoulders
usually use 35 pound weight
but you'll notice none of this takes
more than I mean the weight training at
the gym is going to take the most time
because of the transit
there are weeks when I just skipped that
all together and I'll do the other
things I described
but we're talking about
at most 30 minutes a day
unless it's an activity that doesn't
function for me exclusively as exercise
like an hour-long hike with my dog and
then I'm just throwing on weights to get
some additional stimulation but that's
that's what the that's what the workout
looks like these days I am using a new
device that I've enjoyed I'll just go
grab them to show you what they look
like
okay so for decreasing lower back pain
or alleviating lower back pain and also
helping tremendously with sleep there
are two devices that I've been using for
some time now this one
is called the so right
and you lay on top of this and for those
who can't see this it is a piece of
plastic that looks almost like a u
and the tops of either side of the U are
these rounded plastic
ridges that you lay on top of
and they apply pressure to your psoas so
this is called a sew right device PSO
hyphen rite.com
and
this is a device that I used last night
for instance prior to sleep and I've
been comparing and contrasting that with
another option
which is a lot easier to travel with so
I have traveled for instance when I was
hiking in the mountains and at altitude
I traveled with this so if you look at
this thing here this is the hip hook
and it's more effectively gets into and
you can see how aggressive this looks
right uh you're laying on this so this
really gets into your psoas and can also
get to the iliacus more effectively than
the so right so the I'm not an anatomist
but the the if you think of where your
psoas is let's just say
kind of a few inches up from your iliac
crest like those hip bones that stick
out right under your uh obliques or love
handles depending on your condition
those those hip bones if you go directly
up your sides and then in
towards the center say I don't know
three or four inches and then press
directly towards your spine
this is not a precise description but
you will be getting into your psoas the
iliopsoas the iliacus is going to be
lower down kind of inside
the Cradle of the hip architecture which
is where the hip hook comes in and this
this really works well I've been using
it for the last several weeks on the
road and these two I have found to be
tremendously helpful for improving sleep
often what disrupts my sleep is lower
back tightness and end up having to
flip-flop like a rotisserie chicken from
side to side to side to side which
surprise surprise does not improve your
sleep architecture or quality
so these two devices I found very
helpful let me do another question here
from Michael
and these beans and Swiss chards
keeping me warm here all right so for
Michael what would be your suggested
criteria for choosing podcast to
allocate advertising dollars towards
product slash industry agnostic if
possible
this is a difficult question to answer I
would say because there are a number of
articles that have been written about it
athletic greens
has the most methodical quantitative
and strategic approach to podcast
advertising that I have ever seen in any
company so to the extent that you can
study that
and there are articles that discuss
their approach to podcast advertising I
think it is it is worth looking at
it is not possible I think to make any
answer product slash industry agnostic
because
athletic greens has a high-end premium
product with a very high
LTV customer lifetime value and you can
time bound that let's just say their
value over two years or three years
something like that but it is a product
that has a very low amount of churn in
other words once someone subscribes to
receive athletic greens they tend to
remain a athletic greens user
and this is the type of product that I
think is particularly well suited to
certain types of podcasts especially
long form interview podcasts where ad
reads are host read
very specific I know but athletic greens
is worth studying and then an additional
Factor
that is less discussed because on the
buy side if you were a podcast
Advertiser generally you don't wanna
allocate you don't want to discuss the
implicit value of what I'm going to
describe because it lessens your
bargaining position if you're on the buy
side
for the podcast equation you want to say
okay here is our URL with a code at the
end and people are going to go to this
link we're going to track how much
traffic goes to that link and then they
need to enter this really onerous code
it's Tim zero eight hashtag four three
underscore seven and based on how many
people redeem that code we will see what
the ROI is on our podcasting
advertisement now anyone listening to
the exaggerated example I just gave will
realize there's going to be a tremendous
amount of slippage what does this mean
this means that the vast majority of
people aren't going to remember nor even
if they remember take the time to input
such a code if the savings is for
instance say 10 which is why I almost
always insist that if sponsors are going
to give a discount they make it
compelling enough so that people will
use an actual tracking code because if
they are setting the measure of success
based on a code which most people will
not put in
unless the discount is significant 30 to
50 percent then I am being set up for
failure because somebody who is
especially this is true with larger
companies if there is someone who's a
middle manager VP of you know Junior VP
of marketing or associate director of
marketing who is in charge of monitoring
Roi and they're basing everything on
say the one out of 10 people I refer who
actually fill in a code then they are
deliberately or unknowingly putting
themselves in a position to say the
podcast ad didn't work this fortunately
doesn't happen very often with me but
I'm painting a picture that is
something that applies all over the
industry
so
there are a couple of things here to
keep in mind right there's slippage
number one you're not going to track
anything perfectly unless it goes
through something like a newsletter in
which case now I have access to the data
as well I can look at the click-through
rates and I can identify for instance is
it a copy issue is it a read issue or
and this is very common is it a website
conversion issue so my team spends quite
a bit of time with podcast advertisers
looking at their websites saying Hey
look we can send a bunch of fish towards
your net but your net sucks it's full of
holes right now doesn't make any sense
it's upside down
and we're not going to do it unless your
conversion can be optimized we're more
polite about it than that but
it's critical that
I think for me at least because I care
about having long-term sponsors for
extended periods of time it's a hassle
and very energy intensive for my team to
deal with any type of churn
that I want all pieces of the chain to
function optimally before I put forth
the effort to test all these products
and services and then vet them down to
the top five percent that make the cut
and then do a good read I don't want to
go through all that hassle if someone's
not gonna do the heavy lifting on their
side to ensure optimal conversion I know
we're getting a little off topic but the
reason that I bring all of this up
is allocating advertising dollars how
should you allocate advertising dollars
there are different reasons you may
advertise I'll give an example there is
a billboard in the Bay Area it was on
280.
which takes people from the airport from
SFO to San Francisco and there's this
big billboard and it was a huge tech
company I'm not going to mention the
name because I don't know if they'd like
it but the advertisement
didn't really make any sense to anyone
and
except for one tiny sliver
of the population huge billboard no
doubt very expensive and lots of people
drove by and they're like that's the
dumbest billboard ever it doesn't even
make any sense
and then someone in this group
conversation said actually it makes
perfect sense you just have to realize
who that billboard is for it is for
investment bankers who are visiting the
Bay Area that's it
so if you're looking at that billboard
for conversion purposes and there's some
unique
URL the value is probably going to
amount to zero
if you are looking at it from a customer
acquisition perspective and this was a
gaming company
the value is probably zero if you're
viewing it however through the lens of
cording
the
top operators in the rarified world of
investment banking okay now perhaps you
only need one person or two people or
five people to pay attention to that and
suddenly that can be worth many millions
upon millions of dollars for a given
company
the reason I bring that up is
you should ask yourself who do I want to
know this brand who do I want to
understand the marketing positioning of
this brand
is it for instance the broadest
population possible say all readers of
USA Today and all
viewers of late night television
something like that
or
is it most valuable for me to get in
front of say the audience of Ted would I
want just the two to three thousand
people at Ted
to all be aware of this and that can
dictate your choice of platform so if
you want to say get in front of
New York Times Wall Street Journal
policy makers taste makers directors
producers Etc I know for a fact that
that you can very easily do that through
the podcast or my podcast that is or
through Bible Friday through the
newsletter right and that is highly
highly highly targeted the absolute
numbers may not be large even though the
newsletter's got 2 million subscribers
or so in the grand scheme of things in a
country of whatever the 350 to 400
million people that's not a gigantic
percentage but you don't need a gigantic
percentage if similar to our earlier
conversations you choose the right lead
dominoes and this Maps perfectly to how
I launched
the four hour work week also in choosing
Outlets how did I choose Outlets I was
looking at the first Domino
as the very tightly defined demographic
of say 20 to 35 year old tech savvy
males living in
New York San Francisco and Los Angeles
that was it
and what that allowed me to do as
someone with very little budget
was to take whatever time and capital I
had and to think about four or five
Outlets let's just say at the time
probably Gizmodo Tech crunch
Life Hacker perhaps and a few others and
Robert scoble is a very very influential
blogger at the time if I could get
noticed and some degree of coverage from
these Outlets I would create the
perception of surround sound in so much
as I would appear with the four hour
work week to be ubiquitous to a very
very tightly defined demographic
recognizing that the target the initial
target market is not the total market
and people get all caught up about this
where they're like oh god well what if
we know we need to be inclusive with
everybody if you try to make everyone
your customer no one is going to be your
customer you will fail
99 times out of 100 there is a time to
broaden but it is not in the early
phases in the beginning you need the
strongest foothold and handhold possible
so you need to choose your niche
and this is true with so many products
that end up being mainstream successes
they do not begin by trying to boil the
ocean at once they choose a very
Surgical
precise demographic so I started with
that and the expectation was
if I were able to establish a a critical
mass of attention within that group
that it would then Cascade it would
Cascade from male to female now you have
20 to 35 year old tech savvy females in
the same cities looking at the same
outlets and that is exactly what
happened and then from there the age
would start to bleed out and creep both
younger and older that's exactly what
happened and then from there from those
cities with very high density and large
populations
including a critical mass of people with
broadcast capabilities let's say
bloggers people using Twitter Etc which
launched publicly officially at the same
South by Southwest that the four hour
work week did March of 2007
that if you choose the right initial
dominoes
you can allow Cascades to take care of a
lot of the heavy lifting later but if
you are imprecise in the beginning
you're [ __ ] it just will not work even
if you put them if even if I had a
million dollars to put into the four
hour work week launch and I think I
capped my total expenses at 10 or 20
grand almost all of which went to events
registration and travel and housing for
those events just FYI but if instead of
that 20 grand I'd had a million dollars
number one I would have made
much worse decisions I would have been
much less precise I would have much less
creative and if I had made poor
decisions in the beginning chosen the
wrong dominoes and then tried to fix it
say six months later by pouring money
into it it would have all been cash in a
pile lit on fire on the sidewalk it
wouldn't have done anything so
how the hell do we get onto all this wow
I got a I got a preacher's fire in my
belly I don't know what happened there
oh yes we were talking about suggested
criteria for choosing podcasts to
allocate advertising dollars towards all
right so there you go you got a long
rambling
sermon uh instead of a short answer but
hopefully that at least provides some
questions that might be helpful and a
recognition of some of the invisible
risks and benefits of
choosing through one Criterion alone
if you run a direct to consume or a
direct response business you need
at least some if not most of your
advertising to return a positive Roi or
a media efficiency ratio but you don't
need all of it to do that you don't need
all of it to do that there is some
degree of brand advertising or creation
of awareness which unfortunately
are
kind of smoke screen excuses that get
used to justify a lot of shitty decision
making but you can be very surgical
about how you might approach such things
and in the very beginning for instance
sponsoring the UFC for my Sports
Nutrition Company was exactly that I did
not need the UFC to return all of my
sponsorship
cost it was a strategic decision on a
whole bunch of different levels and you
can afford a couple of those experiments
as long as you recognize or assume that
the trackable Roi will likely be zero
dollars at least in the intermediate
phase
okay so long answer this is from Bradley
my wife is wonderful but she has a bad
relationship with herself what advice do
you have for people to increase
self-love thanks Tim read radical
acceptance by Tara Brock
t-a-r-a-b-r-a-c-h
and I believe she has an online course
that also focuses on radical acceptance
so you can take a look at that as well
from Joel would I ever appear on Joe
Rogan's podcast again or would that
level of exposure bring too much
unwanted Fame at this point in your life
I think it'd be fun to be on Joe's
podcast again it was a lot of fun when I
did it the first two times very long ago
this is before Joe Rogan was the
Undisputed king of all podcasts so I
know he has an overabundance of of guest
options but at some point if it ever
made sense for him I think it would be
fun to be on again
have I ever tried back country skiing
this is from ulrike
could be something for you I just got
some good recommendations in Austria yes
I did my first
Back Country trekking so with conversion
skis that allow you to lift your heel
but then lock in for downhill last year
in the Rockies
and well effectively the Rockies in the
American West and
thought it was absolutely spectacular I
anticipated it would be more like
cross-country skiing which I find very
awkward and slippery and
feels unstable on the knees but using
the touring boots that allow you to
connect and disconnect or Elevate the
heel I absolutely had a blast so yes I
may want those recommendations in
Austria at some point I had a great time
all right you know here I'll answer this
one just as a teaser
this is from Theron I think that is it's
a cool name hopefully I'm pronouncing it
correctly
so here is the question can you give us
some Alpha on your nft project code name
project 555.
is Kev Kev helping you with it when can
we expect more about it can we the
supporters group get first access
so all I'll say
is I will I will confirm that project
555 is in fact me so I will I will give
you that and there will be a lot more
coming soon I do have a lot of
excitement I get giddy just thinking
about it surrounding this it's going to
be [ __ ] ridiculous and completely
absurd I'm just going to warn everyone
in advance it's going to make a lot of
people cover their eyes with their hands
with a huge WTF Tim Ferriss oh my God
I'm sure that some percentage will think
to themselves I'm so disappointed no
doubt they'll tell me that the internet
loves to tell people that I'm so
disappointed I expected so much more so
key to happiness low expectations don't
expect anything other than possibly
letting out an oh my [ __ ] god laugh
when you see this whole thing so for the
time being I will just confirm that
project 555 is in fact Yours Truly
alright guys thank you so much for all
the time hopefully this was helpful I
had a good time there are some great
questions both in the live feed and in
those submitted and I think we will
come to a close right now
at
I am on EST so almost 555 EST which I'll
take is a good omen
all right everybody thank you very much
and have a wonderful evening